foreign
image shows destroyed Vehicles scattered
around the Frontline Village of
novodonetsko in eastern Ukraine which
had a population of several hundred
people before the war Russian State
media shared a video suggesting that a
column of Ukrainian armored vehicles and
Western tanks was destroyed after
running over a minefield
the footage was released around the time
Ukraine's counter-offensive started in
early June 2023
Kiev says the sheer number of Russian
landmines on the battlefield is
hampering its military's push to retake
territory
here's how Russia created one of the
biggest minefields in the world
Ukraine's counter-offensive focused on
the zaparisha and Donetsk regions
Russian held Novo de NASCAR is right in
this area but kiev's forces quickly ran
into obstacles Russia spent months
preparing the 900 mile long front line
with anti-tank ditches concrete blocks
trenches and landmines
it's estimated that approximately sixty
thousand square miles of land more than
one-fourth of the country may now be
littered with anti-personnel and
anti-tank mines
foreign
Security Council secretary in August
estimated that Ukrainian forces were
encountering Fields with up to five
mines per 10 square feet
videos shared online by Russian State
media journalists and pro-war bloggers
show Russia's brand new remote mind
laying system known as zemledelia or
agriculture
first unveiled in 2020 the system made
its combat debut in Ukraine in the early
months of the war according to defense
intelligence firm James
Russian State media say this system can
set a whole Minefield three to nine
miles away using a single Salvo of 50
mine loaded Rockets
the Jane's expert at the journal spoke
with said zemlidelia is one of a number
of systems Russia uses to literally sow
the front line with mines
foreign
the mine feels slowed down Ukrainian
forces and channeled advancing infantry
into positions where there would be an
easy targets for Russian helicopters
artillery and drones
after losing a number of Western tanks
and armored vehicles the Ukrainian
military switched tactics now infantry
are leading the advances through the
minefields on foots
military analysts also said Ukraine has
been firing more artillery as well as
using Western missiles such as British
storm Shadows to Target Russian supply
lines from afar
military experts with Jane says that for
Ukraine time is running out before the
weather changes and large-scale
movements become constrained by the
muddy ground
in mid-august Ukraine's military made
some advances retaking a village some
six miles away from Novo donetska
this shows how while Russian defense
lines remain a major obstacle they can
be penetrated
foreign